بعد الشتاء طويل يخرج سكان عاصمه مولدوفا
للتنزه وجهتهم الاثيره حديقه بوشكين
الرومانسيه
تغير اسم الحديقه في الاونه الاخيره صارت
حديقه ستيفانولمار احد امراء مولدوفا في
القرن السابع عشر لكن تمثال بوشكين لم
يتزحزح من مكانه
هنا ضربنا موعدا مع يوليان قبل الحرب الف
كتابا يتوقع فيه غزو الجيش الروسي
لمولدوفا ورغم ان ما تنبا به لم يحدث حتى
الان فانه لا يزال عند رايه بان توقعاته
قد تصبح حقيقه مرعبه تم التيم التيمم بعد
بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا ادركت ان روايه
اشبه بالواقع اخشى دائما ان تحتل روسيا
مولدوفا لسبب بسيط هو انه اذا انتصرت في
اوكرانيا فربما نكون رقم اثنين في قائمه
بوتين ويمكنهم القدوم الى هنا في غضون
ايام معدوده اخشى اننا في خطر كبير في ظل
هذه الهواجس استضافت مولدوبا قمه اوروبيه
فالتقى القاده في بلده على مقربه من منطقه
طالها نصيب من قصف ميناء اوديسا الاوكراني
العام الماضي
وزير الدفاع في مولدوفا اكد قبيل القمه ان
بلاده لا يهددها خطر هجوم عسكري وشيك بل
تواجه حربا هجينه تشنها روسيا لقلب نظام
لمعرفه طبيعه الحرب التي تستهدف زعزعه
استقرار مولدوفا كما يقول وزير الدفاع
التقينا
الذي بادر الى انشاء موقع متخصص في مواجهه
حملات التضليل وفك تشفير الاخبار الكاذبه
بيتري يتحدث عن حمله قويه قادره على زعزعه
النظام في مولدوفا
يحاولون بطرق شتى اثاره البلبله في
مولدوفا روجوا مثلا ان النيتو في طريقه
الى دخول مولدوفا وان حكومتها اعدت ثلاثه
الاف نعش بعض هذه المعلومات الكاذبه لها
عواقب وخيمه وقد سببت فعلا الذعره بين
المواطنين لسوء الحظ المؤسسات الحكوميه في
مولدوفا ليست مهيئه بما يكفي للرد عمليا
وبفعاليه على هذا النوع من الاخبار
الزائفه
تعيش مولدوفا ايضا في خوف دائم بسبب
احتمال زعزعه استقرارها باستخدام ورقه
اخرى نحن هنا على بعد كيلومترات القليل من
منطقه
المواليه لروسيا حيث تنشر موسكو جنودا لها
وتملك مخزنا كبيرا من الذخيره
تدير نفسها كدوله فيها مقر للبرلمان
ورئاسه علمها يرفرف جنبا الى جنب مع العلم
الروسي هنا تبدو الحياه وكانها تجمدت
وتوقفت في زمن الماضي السوفيتي لا تزال
بقايا تلك الحقبه مرئيه ورغم طلباتها
المتكرره لم تحصل على اعتراف المجموعه
الدوليه نور الدين بوزيان الجزيره كيشيناو
مولدوفا